growing up I never like brussel sprouts
but I think I finally cracked that code
these honey bomic Sprouts were so good
crispy sweet you got to try it let's get
into it first things first get one pound
of fresh brussels sprouts now their
Frozen stuff and give them a good wash
and dry next preheat your oven to 400° f
with the bacon tray inside now you want
to remove any hanging skin cut the ends
off and then cut them in half just like
this and add them to a large mixing bowl
we're going to hit them with some oeo
then we got garlic powder on powdered
salt some white pepper some balsamic
vinegar and some honey give that a nice
mix for this and many other amazing
recipes check out the link in my bio for
my cookbook once everything is
Thoroughly mixed bring out your heated
bacon tray add some oil you want to
place your Brussels face side down just
like this from here we're going to bake
it at 400° fhe for 25 to 30 minutes
folks plate up I hit it with a balsamic
glaze so good